you must be getting love wherever you go
because the Cubs winning the World
Series I I can't imagine I mean actually
I can because I remember the Red Sox
winning for the first time and there had
been a long drought and people lost
their minds Cubs 1908 that's an even
longer drought the love must be insane
it was a long time coming yeah yeah that
the fans have been overwhelming the
support it's unbelievable seeing how
many came out to the parade and out to
every game all season long I mean
they've they've been very patient and
loyal throughout this time and I mean we
we couldn't believe the overwhelming
response after we won I mean not just in
Chicago not just an Illinois or or even
in the United States it's just all over
the world there's so many Cub fans the
amount of emotion I mean I think that
was something that sometimes it's hard
to tell like okay fans seem happy but
the amount of emotion that was coming
through and I was watching it on
television the emotion coming through
the screen was intense even exposed to
so you must be I mean people must walk
up to you just crying wanting to hug you
people are crying and literally but I
mean generations of their family that
didn't get a chance to see that I mean
they're living this experience and just
thinking of all their family throughout
the years and I mean on the parade we
saw people crying you know screaming at
us they were intense people climbing up
in trees hanging out of buildings that's
stupid shouldn't hang out of the
building that's really stupid they did
it though yeah yeah it was incredible
just just seeing the support now okay
game-winning double 10th inning okay
what's going through your mind you get
to the plate
I would I try to sometimes think what
would it be like to be this guy in that
situation and I can't I can't imagine
what it's like to get them in that
situation and have to put that bat on
that ball what's going through your head
well I'll tell you what I was just as
nervous as anybody else would be going
up there actually they intentionally
walked one of our best hitters right
before me in the lineup to get to me
yeah so there's a part of you as a
baseball player that you know your pride
is a little hurt like they'd rather face
me than that guy so right you know it
kind of makes you really really want to
do it at that right let's go hit sober
up here yeah yeah it's not your nickname
I just made that up if it catches on
yeah
hey no hit but so you get up there and
you have to almost get probably into a
Zen space because I mean I've always
think of what I would do and I'm as such
an ass I if were if I were in that
situation I'd do the thing rod point for
a homerun always thought that that's
what I would do and then strike out
drop the bat and be like you're welcome
what is seriously going through your
head I mean we I had to block out all
the emotion any sort of emotion that I
felt at that time I just had to say put
it aside try to go up there just don't
try to do too much because if you as an
athlete if you try to be the hero in
that situation it never works out you
really just have to try to stay within
yourself I knew it was a really tough
pitcher on the mound I was facing and I
was just hoping to get a ball that I
could do something with and he really
got me into a tough count early in the
count I I was really uncomfortable he
got me down and I was just flailing at
balls District emergency hack and then
the last one was just over the plate and
up enough that I could get enough of the
barrel to it when I hit it I just I
think I lost consciousness I mean I'm
running to first day as you did you
actually collapsed it and you were in a
coma for a week I didn't remember
anything until like I was jumping at
second base you know with my fists in
the air so we have that hit I do we have
the footage of that hit or no maybe we
have a draw yeah I just want to see that
again
and so that is down the line yeah
[Applause]
I jumped my helmet flew off I mean there
was nothing that doesn't happen in my
business in comedy if I tell a joke and
it does well I don't start going yeah no
I shouldn't it's very off-putting
it really hurts the next joke but yeah
so you do that and in that moment it's
just there's got to be just an
incredible amount of adrenaline and it
really was I mean I at that point in the
game we had we had had the lead early we
lost it and then to get it back I think
we just felt like we knew right then we
were gonna win the game it was just a
matter of time to get to those last
three outs and you guys saw me on the
video as I came out just I mean I was
basically jumping up and down like a
little kid it makes you feel like a
little kid playing the game again
you